[Applaudissements]
jeudi m il ya une grosse clim sur le
plateau j'ai senti comment ça va mais
j'aime et bienvenue à tous pas mort ça
va eric naulleau et qui est déjà moi car
la guerre us vous le savez c'est l'avant
dernier jour de la fashion week la
fashion week c'est ya des défis et tout
le temps c'est un truc de ouf voilà
j'adore et je me suis dit aujourd'hui
nous aussi on va être en grand couturier
vous avez remarqué voilà moi je suis en
quarts la gare proche et ils vont tous
faire leur entrée
vous allez voir c'est du très très lourd
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon ben ça soit fait qui je suis
jean paul gaultier
[Applaudissements]
alors
sow
[Musique]
je suis une jonction armani
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oh
non
[Applaudissements]
m
je suis tir outils groupe c en question
du bio
alors je rappelle que si vous répondez
mal sachez que jean patates on verra la
furie pourquoi l'athlète français yohann
diniz at-il fait parler de lui aux
mondiaux de doha au qatar il a été
arrêté pour avoir bu de l'alcool dans la
rue
il s'est entraîné dans les couloirs de
son hôtel il a refusé de serrer la main
de l'émir on a découvert qui est caché
un javelot dans son slip en or je dirais
qu'il a refusé de serrer la main de la
madeleine de l'émile c'est une mauvaise
réponse
[Applaudissements]
jean pas mal vient d'envoyer la police
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire dit
isabelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez y
le tas
attendez attendez c'est mon fils allô
allô allô oui je suis à l'antenne série
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui non
tu pourras le reste et lettres a b c
son chip adc socip
là dessus
[Applaudissements]
non
c'est que ça fait partie des ces coiffes
et des saluts pascal bonsoir merci c'est
à paris qu'on se connaît peu on sort le
salut tu vas bien ouais ça va alors tu
es passé toi oui je suis passé une
émission tournée j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps je suis passé quand même nos vies
tu aimais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gilles verdez est de retour j'ai
découvert une étude on l'a demandé aux
français de donner une note à leur
physique
et qu'est ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
demandé aux chroniqueurs de donner une
note physique à chacun de notre
chroniqueur et là ils vont donner la
note qui pensent avoir enfin qui se
donnerait on voulait actuellement le
plus beau des humoristes celui qui est
président et moi je suis venu parler de
ma compagnie aérienne
[Applaudissements]
jean michel maire jean michel maire il
sait me laisser me 8 sur 10 la moyenne
donnée par les autres chroniqueurs
regarder et la pire note
sachez que c'est eric naulleau qui moule
amis
[Applaudissements]
dix huit mois il s'est mis cette année
sur l'iss voici la note donnée par les
chroniqueurs 4 la pire note qu'il y ait
calé ses deux sur dix c'est kelly qui
t'a mis d'accord avec deux sur dix
seulement c'est parce que je savais
qu'il allait se mettre une bonne heure
mais ce n'est pas tout justifier
l'oncle et le mal est fait vous vous
êtes donné 9,1 matthieu delormeau sais
pas me dit on est passé 40 ans je me
suis relevé 03 je vous le dis je vous le
dit mathieu la meilleure note jusqu'à
présent c'était kelly avec comme elle
est et kelly à combien est à 8,3 soit
déviée combien 8,9 j'ai deux fils elle
s'en fout non
c'est très bien tu connais tu connais le
nom de tout le monde ici mais on est
évidemment bien évidemment c'est qu'il a
la cua csa le csa 1
[Applaudissements]
les gens ne vous appelle pas passer ses
messages lui ce qui lui en prison ferme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
lui mais ça à thierry moreau en moins
cher la dame à côté bella depuis 94
[Applaudissements]
tantôt c'est côte à côte a fait la java
ça va t'asseoir
[Applaudissements]
pathak hier c'est yves hinse qui est
venu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
riga lettonie elle reconnaît plus
personne n'a ri d'art
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tél
blanc y en a qui est vraiment pas prêt à
recevoir les conseils de battue c'est
eric naulleau awadi donc il a terminé
zemmour et balaye le termine aussi loin
le terminator on a tous à sa mère
[Musique]
rien
ainsi toute la nano est arrivé lundi
par ailleurs un empire même légère la
cour les maquettes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]